-The president bragged about
his TV ratings
during the coronavirus pandemic,
suggested states
were lying about how many
ventilators they need
and blamed health care workers
for the lack of masks.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
You know, we're all just
trying to get through
this quarantine period
any way we can.
For many, it means working from
home while watching the kids.
For others, it means
taking up new hobbies.
And for many essential workers,
it means having to go to work
without adequate pay,
protections, or sick leave.
And then for everyone else,
there's, you know, liquor.
As you can see here, I have
a bottle of scotch
I've been working on
all morning.
I like to ease into it
by just a little nip,
just the littlest of nip
into my coffee mug.
And then I just
sanitize my hands in that
and then I drink directly
from the old bottle.
Mmm.
Now, apparently I'm not
the only one,
because one of
President Trump's staunchest
allies on Fox News,
Jeanine Pirro,
aka the
Real Housewife of Westchester,
seemed like she might have
dipped into the sauce
on Saturday night while
filming her show from home.
The show started late
after what she called
"technical difficulties"
and got weirder from there.
-Welcome back. It's good
to be with you tonight.
And, uh, we apologize for
the technical difficulties.
Welcome back to "Justice."
Just the other day,
the president talked,
or was hoping, about the
possibility of reopening
everything on Easter Sunday.
And in a way where we could kind
of come out of this quarantine,
as loose as it may be,
that we're involved in.
And Lisa Boothe,
a Fox News contributor,
is here to talk with us tonight
about whether or not...
-Hey, Judge.
-...that's even a possibility.
How are you, Lisa?
-Wow, I understand having
a sip to take the edge off,
but she sounds like she's about
to grab a microphone
and ruin her
daughter's wedding.
"Deejay, turn off
the electric slide.
I have a few bombs to drop
before the cake comes out.
How are ya now, Lisa?"
What were the technical
difficulties?
Did the labels get switched
on your Ambien and Xanax
and your water
and grain alcohol?
Someone tell Judge Jeanine
to stay six feet away
from the liquor cabinet.
Look, I can't tell for sure
if she was drunk or not.
But that's definitely the face
you make when you're trying
to act like you're not drunk,
you know, like you're
in a conversation
and you're not
following a word
the other person is saying
so you overcompensate
by nodding and smiling
like a lunatic and saying stuff
like, "Oh, yeah.
Totally. Good point.
Yeah, man,
my thoughts exactly."
I'm shocked she didn't do
the rest of her show
with a lampshade on her head
singing karaoke
from the top of her desk.
Of course at this point,
to defend President Trump
on national television,
you have to be
at least a little bit drunk.
This morning, for example, as
courageous health care workers
were exposing themselves
to danger
and begging for supplies,
the president was dialing in
for his weekly
Skype therapy session
with the "Fox & Friends"
and complaining about
absolute nonsense.
-You know, I've gotten from
fair people, you know,
a lot of accolades,
and I don't want the accolades,
but it's just in terms
of a fact.
Then you hear Nancy Pelosi,
who's, you know,
somehow there's something wrong
with the woman
because she knows
what we've done.
And don't forget, she was
playing the impeachment game,
you know, her game
where she ended up
looking like a fool.
It just went on for years.
I mean, if you think about it,
that's all she did.
She didn't do anything.
She couldn't get bills passed.
She's controlled by the radical
left, by AOC plus three.
And, you know,
I have to say this,
it's never pleasant,
but my poll numbers
are the highest they've ever
been because of her.
If you look at Russia,
Russia lost 50 million people
at World War II, 50 million.
They were fighting along
with us.
They were our partner.
And now we don't talk to Russia,
we talk to Germany.
I mean, look, it's fine.
I want to talk to Germany.
My father was born --
you know, Germany is --
it's in my heritage.
-He was definitely about to say
his father was born in Germany
even though he was born
in New York.
The man doesn't even know
where his father was born.
He needs to see his own father's
birth certificate.
So it really wasn't that
personal, Obama.
Maybe it's because Trump himself
wasn't actually born anywhere.
He was just summoned by some
teens in the woods
playing with a Ouija board.
"You guys want to make some
investments?"
Also, look at the three of them.
They're captives in their own
homes, getting yelled at
by a senile old man.
It's like a cross between
FaceTime with your grandpa
and a "Saw" movie.
It's like an escape room
where the theme is,
Grandpa has been watching
History Channel all day
and now he wants to yell at you.
Now, the coronavirus pandemic
has brought much of the world
to a halt,
with hospitals overwhelmed
and courageous health care
workers on the front lines
heroically exposing themselves
to danger.
There are now more than
700,000 cases globally
with roughly a third
of the world's population
under lockdown,
or as Trump put it
during his press conference
on Sunday night...
-It's up to 151 countries.
So when we say our nation,
our nation and the world,
when you think.
Think of it.
151 countries.
Somebody said to me today that
wasn't in this particular world,
they didn't know that
we had that many countries.
-151 countries.
Thanks for the fun fact,
President Kid From
"Jerry Maguire."
"There are some important
developments I want to share
with you, but first,
did you know the human head
weighs eight pounds?
Because mine weighs 50."
Also, it was definitely
that you
didn't know we had
that many countries.
Or knowing the Trump
Administration, it was
the Deputy Secretary of Knowing
How Many Countries There Are.
"I thought there were
only a few --
America, Mexico, Europe,
Canada, China,
China-da, Chinatown,
Chipotle, Xanadu, and...
-...the United States.
-Also, it's an important detail
that it's in 151 countries,
but Trump always
immediately blows it
by focusing on the unimportant
part that people already know.
"COVID-19 continues to spread.
And you know, the 19 is for
the year it was discovered,
not the age it was.
I knew that.
But when I told someone,
they made a face like,
'What?'
So that's just a fun piece
of bar trivia
the next time
you go out drinking."
[ As Pirro ]
"Did someone say drinking?!"
Real John Leguizamo here
doing multiple voices
at the same time.
So virtually the entire world
has been transformed
by this pandemic.
In fact, in Italy
things are so bad,
mayors have had to resort
to drastic measures
to keep people
from going outside.
-In Italy, strict
government restrictions
designed to stop the spread
of the coronavirus
have not stopped people
from heading outside.
Tens of thousands have been
reported for breaking
the restrictions
in a nation that's seen
more coronavirus deaths
than anywhere in the world,
and this is prompting outraged
officials to use social media
to vent their frustrations.
-Ping-Pong is not allowed.
Go home and play
on the PlayStation.
You cannot stay here.
Don't look at me like that.
You should be respectful.
There is a decree.
I am the mayor of this city,
and as the mayor of this city,
I will make everyone respect
this decree.
Go home now.
-Hundreds of students will be
graduating soon.
I hear that some want
to host a party.
We will send the police
and we will send them
with flamethrowers.
-Of course, the only thing
scarier than a flamethrower
is an angry Italian mayor.
Italians are great at social
distancing because you have to
stand six feet away during
a normal conversation
to avoid getting hit
with the hand gestures.
Because if they're talking,
their hands are flying,
and it doesn't matter
what they're talking about.
[ Italian accent ]
"You know what I like?
I like a nice cup of coffee
on the balcony."
You get it.
Italy's experience
has been harrowing,
and the fear is
that it's a preview
of what's about to
happen here.
And this is important
to remember --
just because you can't
personally witness it
doesn't mean
it's not happening.
Here's how one health care
professional put it.
-What would the zombie
apocalypse be like
if we only had verbal
descriptions of zombies
but could never show them?
-That's a chilling description
of what's going on,
and also a reminder that it's
hard to describe zombies.
You'd say they're pale,
angry ghouls
with their hair falling out
and they look like
they've been decomposing
underground for years.
And most people would guess,
"Oh, is that those guys,
those guys who
work for the president?"
Health care professionals
on the front lines
are begging for
life-saving supplies
like masks and ventilators.
In epicenters like Detroit,
New York, and New Orleans,
they're describing
the situation as a tsunami,
calling it apocalyptic
and comparing it to a war zone.
An ER doctor in Queens
put it this way
in an interview with
"The New York Times."
-I don't have the support
that I need
and even just the materials
that I need physically
to take care of my patients,
and it's America.
And we're supposed to be
a first world country.
-[ As President Trump ]
"It's harder to be
a first world country
than you think.
Did you know there are
151 of them?
At least."
And yeah, we're supposed to be
a first world country.
Instead, our doctors
can't get masks,
our hospitals can't get
ventilators,
and our president can't get
a suit that doesn't look
like it was stolen from
Shaquille O'Neal.
I mean, that right there,
that is what happens
when you can't even tell
the truth to your tailor.
"So how tall are you?"
"Seven feet. No, it's true.
Many people, many people
are saying it."
So front line health care
workers are describing
a dire situation and telling us
they need supplies immediately.
But don't worry, the president
is laser-focused on the crisis.
-"I am a great friend
and admirer of the Queen
and the United Kingdom.
It was reported that Harry and
Meghan who left the Kingdom
would reside permanently
in Canada.
Now that they have left Canada
for the U.S., however,
the U.S. will not pay
for their security protection.
They must pay."
-What the [bleep] are you
talking about?
Harry and Meghan
are moving to L.A.?
Where are you getting
your celebrity news
during the pandemic?
I know it's not
"People" magazine because
even "People" magazine
is covering the coronavirus.
Seriously, was anyone in America
worried about this?
Honestly, was there
a single person
out of 300 million people
sitting there on Sunday,
muttering to themselves,
"We better not be paying
for Harry and Meghan's
security protection.
That would be large-scale
tragedy."
Also, how does Trump even hear
about this stuff?
Is he surfing TMZ during
his task force meetings
with Dr. Fauci?
"Fauci, Fauci, Fauci, I'm going
to cut you off real quick.
Did you see that Kanye lied
about his phone call
with Taylor Swift?
That is ice cold, Fauci.
I mean, I was Team Kanye, but
now I'm definitely Team Kanye.
Fauci?
Fauci, I got you.
I made you touch
your face again.
You're not better than me,
Fauci.
I'm just joking,
you make me laugh.
You're my best friend."
So Trump fired off a random
tweet about Harry and Meghan,
and yet it's not even remotely
the worst thing he tweeted
this weekend because
he also bragged
about the ratings for his press
conferences during the pandemic.
"Because the 'ratings' of my
news conferences are so high,
'"Bachelor' finale,"
"Monday Night Football"
type numbers,' according
to "The New York Times,"
the Lamestream Media
is going crazy."
And then later he tweeted,
"President Trump
is a ratings hit."
You're comparing your pandemic
briefings to "The Bachelor"?
Because at this point, I would
rather go to Peter's mom Barb
for coronavirus updates.
"All I know is after she showed
up three hours late
to our meeting in Australia,
Madi needs to socially distance
herself from my son."
I don't watch "The Bachelor,"
so I don't get that joke.
Also I'm not saying it to say
I'm better than you.
I mainlined "Love Is Blind"
in two nights, and, guys,
when this is over, we need
to talk about Jessica
because she's a real
Judge Jeanine.
Also, people aren't tuning in
because they all love you.
They're tuning in because
they're trapped inside
and their only choices are
watching you
or digging through Netflix
trying to find
a British crime show
they haven't seen yet.
"Honey? Honey, did we watch
'Inspector Pinderberry'?"
"Yeah, remember?
The killer was the lorry driver
and Pinderberry caught him
burying the body
in the Yorkshire Moors?"
"Ha, ha, that's right.
No one outsmarts
Inspector Pinderberry."
Also, we're only trapped
inside watching you
because you kept ignoring
the crisis and pretending
it would go away
until it was too late.
We're forced to stay inside
and watch you
because you screwed up.
More people than ever are
playing Scrabble right now,
but it sure as hell isn't
because Scrabble is fun.
"Monday Night Football"
could score huge ratings too
if every week they released
millions of large exotic
wildcats onto the streets
in major cities and
forced everyone to stay inside.
We could either stay inside
and watch the Jaguars
or go outside
and get eaten by one.
And then during his press
conference on Sunday night,
as experts were warning
that we could see as many as
100,000 to 200,000 deaths
from the pandemic,
Trump decided it was
a good time to double down
and to brag about his ratings.
-As "The New York Times"
said, we have
"Monday Night Football"
type ratings.
But even they said that the
ratings are like
"Monday Night Football"
ratings,
And that these are like
"Bachelor" finale --
that's their end.
When the big deal happened --
I have no idea what happened
because I'm too busy
working on this.
Someday you will tell me
what happened.
-No, we won't.
That's your punishment.
You have to watch it yourself,
months after everyone else
when nobody wants to talk
about it anymore.
And at dinner parties,
you'll say,
"Did you guys see
'The Bachelor'?"
And people will say,
"We don't want to talk about
'The Bachelor.'"
And then you'll have to say,
"Well, did you hear how many
countries there are?
I know, but do you know?"
Trump is bragging about
TV ratings and his own
disastrous response
to the crisis
even after intelligence
briefings
and his own health secretary
tried to warn him
that it was serious.
In fact, "The Washington Post"
reported that
Health Secretary Alex Azar
had asked for $2 billion
to buy respirator masks
and other supplies
for a depleted federal stockpile
of emergency medical equipment.
The $2 billion request
was cut to $500 million,
and "The New York Times"
reported that after considering
the $1 billion price tag
for ventilators,
the White House had
second thoughts.
So you couldn't spare
a few billion
for emergency medical supplies
and ventilators
as a deadly virus
was spreading,
but you had trillions
lying around
for a massive corporate tax cut
a few years ago?
You know what? Next time
Trump wants to dole out
trillions in tax cuts to
corporations and the wealthy,
we should get that Italian mayor
over to light the bill on fire
with his flamethrower.
It would be like
a Quentin Tarantino movie.
And now after repeatedly
ignoring the crisis,
pitting the states
against each other,
and bragging about
his TV ratings,
Trump is actually suggesting
that state officials
and hospitals are either
lying about what they need
or possibly even
stealing supplies.
First he said this...
-New York is a, uh,
bigger deal,
but it's going to go also.
But I have a feeling that
a lot of the numbers
that are being said
in some areas
are just bigger than
they're going to be.
I don't believe you need
40,000 or 30,000 ventilators.
You know, you go into
major hospitals sometimes,
they'll have two ventilators.
And now all of a sudden
they're saying,
"Can we order
30,000 ventilators?"
And, you know, they say,
like Governor Cuomo and others,
that say, "We want, you know,
30,000 of them."
30,000?
Think of this.
You know, you go to hospitals,
they'll have one in a hospital.
And now all of a sudden
everybody's asking
for these vast numbers.
-What do you mean,
all of a sudden?
Yes, yes, all of a sudden
there's a pandemic,
which means all of a sudden
a bunch of people
need ventilators.
Pandemics aren't weddings.
They don't send you
a "save the date" card.
Although based on how you
ignored repeated warnings
that this was a possibility,
you'd probably throw that
in the trash, too.
I mean, have you not
been paying attention
to, like, any of the news
besides your own ratings
and what Harry and Meghan
are up to?
Somebody please, for the love
of God, squeeze some information
about ventilators into
the celebrity quotes section
of "Us Weekly."
Nick Jonas says of his marriage
to Priyanka Chopra,
"She's such a breath
of fresh air,
and speaking of fresh air,
New York needs
40,000 lifesaving ventilators
because of
the exponential growth of an
incredibly infectious disease."
But Trump's grotesque conspiracy
theories about
the urgent lack of medical
supplies didn't stop there.
On Sunday night, he implied
something fishy was also
going on with the lack of masks
in New York City hospitals,
implying that
heroic medical professionals
who are literally
putting their lives at risk
might be hoarding
or stealing the masks.
-They've been delivering for
years 10,000 to 20,000 masks.
Okay, it's a New York hospital,
very --
it's packed all the time.
How do you go from 10,000
to 20,000 to 300,000?
10,000 to 20,000 masks
to 300,000,
even though this is different.
Something's going on.
And you ought to look into it
as reporters.
Where are the masks going?
Are they going
out the back door?
I would like them
to check that,
because I hear stories
like that all the time.
You know, we're delivering
millions and millions
of different products,
and all we do is hear that,
"Can you get some more?"
So I think people
should check that,
because there's something
going on.
I don't think it's hoarding.
I think it's maybe worse
than hoarding.
-I'm not wearing a mask,
but if I did, I would remove it
to make sure you could hear me
clearly when I say,
[bleep] off.
Trump thinks they might be
stealing masks
because he would
definitely steal masks.
Trump is so deeply
and completely corrupt,
he can't even imagine someone
having a legitimate motivation.
I'm surprised he hasn't opened
a press conference saying,
"Bad news --
ventilators went missing.
Good news -- you guys, we found
a corresponding amount
of Trump-olators,
which are very affordable."
Think about how grotesque
this is.
Health care professionals are
courageously putting their lives
on the line, and Trump is
baselessly accusing them
of stealing masks
and lying about
how many ventilators they need
while bragging about
his TV ratings.
He's either a sociopath,
or he's been stealing
from Jeanine Pirro's
liquor cabinet,
which would explain why he often
slurs his words like a drunk.
-10,000 known or suspes --
gang members.
Advising law markers.
Will not be toleri--
-We had a chance to avoid the
fate we're currently suffering,
and our president squandered it
by ignoring the problem
for weeks and then pretending
it would go away.
Now health care professionals
are putting themselves in danger
and begging for supplies,
and the president instead
is accusing them of stealing
while bragging about
his TV ratings.
When this is all over
and the history of this moment
is written, the kindest thing
you'll be able to say
about Trump is that...
-Ended up looking like a fool.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Hey, just a reminder,
if you've been watching
our lockdown "Closer Looks"
online,
they're also airing on NBC
as part of our full show again,
so you can watch it there.
Thank you so much. Stay safe.
Wash your hands. We love you.